fans of the office are jumping all over
any possibility of the dunder mifflin
gang
getting back together and it is
happening sort of
thanks to brian baumgardner aka kevin
and his new spotify podcast on oral
history of the office
i wanted to eat a pig in a blanket
in a blanket the show is much
bigger now than it ever was then that's
what she said
it's the number one streamed on
netflix and the first day of the
pandemic
250 million minutes were consumed
just that day alone the office was
almost
canceled its first two years john
krasinski and kevin
used to throw the football between takes
so it was written into the show
[Applause]
those are just a couple secrets revealed
in the more than 100
hours of interviews with steve carell
jenna fisher rayne wilson and
john look at that brian also interviewed
the office's
number one fan duh the fact that
i i appear in a billy eilish song it's
like
one of the best movies i've ever seen in
my life
how is that even possible right
yeah the other day we learned that john
krasinski wore a wig at one point
you didn't know that i didn't know that
god looks ridiculous in that wig
he was filming the clooney movie uh
leather heads
that's right he had a little buzz cut
yeah and they but they wanted his little
sexy floppy hair
[Music]
the other day i was interviewing leslie
aka stanley
he told me he had auditioned for the
role of stanley before
i did i did i auditioned for stanley i
went in
and auditioned for stanley and uh i i
read the part
uh as though it was kevin leslie david
baker is trying to keep stanley's legacy
alive
he's got a kickstarter going to make his
own spin-off he's trying to raise 300
000 with 18 days to go it's at just
under 52 grand
there are layers of stanley that had not
been explored
and the fans have been asking for that
exploration so
you know we're going to try to provide
that for them i sit on my porch all day
carving
birds what's the one kevin line they say
to you or they want to hear from you
usually it is it is a it is a
mention of the chili it's probably the
thing i do best
and i would say nice is probably
up there
[Music]